hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
hallo ich will auch dabei bleibt es auch
dabei
heute gehts leckere wraps und zwar habe
ich vor chili con carne webs zu machen
also bisher mit einer hackfleisch
füllung mit bohnen und es wird richtig
lecker die raps habe ich jetzt schon
gebacken die sind schon bereit und jetzt
werden wir die füllung zu bereiten
ich habe hier schon mal 400 gramm rinder
hackfleisch in zwei esslöffel olivenöl
angebraten
dann brauche ich noch zwei kleine
zwiebeln oder eine große zweite ließ
drei esslöffel tomatenmark 100
milliliter wasser etwas honig einen
teelöffel salz eine prise zucker
ich habe ich noch gewürze und zwar einen
halben teelöffel cayennepfeffer inhalten
teelöffel chili einen viertel teelöffel
kreuzkümmel und eine wette teelöffel
curry wer möchte noch etwas tabasco
pfeffer und 150 gramm meist aus der dose
ja du hast vielleicht noch nie geil zu
sagen vergessen was denn die sli aus
stimme dir vergessen schon alles hier
noch ein bisschen bitter schokolade der
mich tatsächlich vergessen denn ich
finde die kommt noch mal zum schluss mit
rein und macht das ganze also das runde
ding kompletten gewinne jetzt vielleicht
nicht vorstellen wenn man nicht kennt
aber es ist wirklich sehr lecker das ist
die geheime zutaten
natürlich habe was vergessen zerlegt es
kommt rein
banide extrakt könnte man sogar auch
reinmachen aber ich nehme es wird also
ich hab jetzt wie gesagt rinderhack
fleisch angebraten
jetzt werde ich die zwiebeln und fein
würfeln
für die chips sich jetzt handschuhe an
denn ansonsten habe ich alles an der
hand hält und diesen mit schafen
die caravans mit renault rad genau ich
hoffe du bist stark genug seine musiker
nicht raus obwohl sie nicht raus wenn
jetzt nicht so ganz schaffen mit dann
wird die kerne mit raum habe kein
problem ging schloss die jetzt mit ran
ich mag es beim nächsten die pfanne
schaltet jetzt wieder ein
denn jetzt kann es direkt weiter gehen
als passiert jetzt hier auch jetzt noch
mit dem öl das heißt der welt gehalt
reicht mir auf jeden fall gebe ich dir
recht geben und trägt dazu mit mama für
etwas zwei minuten mit angebraten
du hast jetzt gemacht erlebt man in
schutz
jetzt gebe ich noch das tomatenmark wird
das so dass wir dann mit angebraten und
dann auch gleich noch die gewürze
nochmalig durchführen
das riecht schon klasse werden nicht
vorbei die chili chance wird lehnen hans
steigen finde ich nicht mit riecht man
sollte dieses café noch raus und den
kreuzkümmel über rang 17
also das was mit dem rest kann ich auch
im herzlichen runterschalten
es gibt noch etwa einen halben teelöffel
honig mit rain man glaubt gar toni wenn
ihr die möglichkeit habt ein imker honig
in rain in wohnzonen dann jetzt noch mit
körper gut abschmecken
jetzt alles erstmal gut durchrühren
gebe ich zum schluss noch den meist mit
dazu ich will ein bisschen ab freispruch
gleich probieren und die schokolade
ich muss wahrscheinlich noch ein
bisschen flüssigkeit mit dazugeben und
was jetzt noch vergessen habe bei mir
kommen jetzt noch frische
cocktailtomaten mit dazu da habe ich
jetzt 100 gramm und die werde ich jetzt
aber vorher vierteln hier noch ein
bisschen flüssigkeit rainer kann es
nämlich noch mal gut auf kochen alles zu
sein
und jetzt kommen noch die tomaten mit
dazu die werden dann nur etwa 30
sekunden mitgekocht nochmal auf höchster
stufe stellen und dann aber die
hackfleischsoße schon mal fährt ist
richtig
wer möchte kann natürlich noch mit etwas
tabasco nachwürzen
aber ihr müsst einfach mal schauen ob
die schärfe schon reicht also das nicht
ganz so scharf mag nimmt wahrscheinlich
viel weniger auf jeden fall jetzt
gespannt auch selten also erst mit dem
kochen eine geschmacksprobe aber richtig
natürlich ist das ist wirklich sehr
kurzer aber ich werde hier gleich noch
wohnen mieter zu machen und später gibt
es noch so eine schwanz soße und die
neutralität des es gibt verschiedene
schärfen das sieht mein kopf ist auch
schwer für unterhalt es ist ja alles
scharf also komplett geschäft das ist
richtig scharf aber richtig aber sehr
gut
während das hackfleisch ist noch
abkühlen bei dir wohnen zu bereiten und
zwar werden die ganz scharf in der
pfanne angebraten und es gibt noch mal
einen richtig tollen geschmack
dafür brauche ich eine dose wohnen in
essig olivenöl 1 prise salz einen halben
teelöffel kreuzkümmel eine violette und
etwas pfeffer jetzt für die pfanne
richtig stark erhitzt als sie muss
wirklich sehr heiß werden
jetzt gebe ich das olivenöl rhein müsse
aufpassen dass spritzt ganz toll
deswegen gebe ich jetzt die bohnen mit
dazu am besten direkt von spritzschutz
nehmen ist eigentlich über kopfschutz
aber dennis akris spritzschutz
umschwenke pfanne ein bisschen und die
müssen jetzt ganz stark angebracht
werden
das heißt ja jedes böhnchen gibt ein
krönchen und ich glaube dass wir eine
ganze sinfonie aber wirklich lecker
chili und bohnen
jetzt kann ich schon mal die limetten
schale abreiben ich glaube so ein
bisschen die schärfe kann es sein
quartal und s100 einfach alles ab und
ich finde die mitte passt sowieso
perfekt mir dazu macht die ganze schule
machen den grünen was hilft die ganzen
linie rein jetzt die limette so ein
bisschen massieren dann kommt nämlich
der saft besser aus beim rasieren und
dann wenn ich hier schon mal den saft
auspressen
die limite die schale kann übrigens
und wenn die boden dann so aussehen also
diesen aufgeplatzt ich habe auch hier so
ein paar röstaromen und die sind schon
dunkel geworden
dann kann ich sie mit dem limettensaft
ablöschen und gibt direkt noch kreuz
zimmern und sagt ihr dazu
das ist also schon mal mein leben dann
noch ein bisschen pfeffer und dann sind
die es auch schon bereit
neues stelle gleich die raps fertig ich
brauche jetzt noch 200 gramm schmerzt
als im pfeffer und chicorée salat
nämlich zuerst mal den salat und den
schneide ich jetzt in ganz feine
streifen und er passt geschmacklich hat
gut dazu darf zwar so ein bisschen
bitter aber ich finde so in der
kombination passt gut denn jetzt gar
nicht mehr könnt ihr auch einen anderen
salat nehme eisbergsalat oder kopfsalat
was ihr wollt wo bei kopfweh wieder zu
weich 1 salat ist schön knackig also
schon knackigen salat
den schmand vermische ich jetzt noch mit
salz und pfeffer
viel braucht nicht denn der schwanz soll
eigentlich die schärfe und so weiter bis
neutralisieren
so jetzt können wir direkt füllen ich
habe hier schon gebacken und vorbereitet
dies sind jetzt nicht so ganz leicht das
heißt vor der verwendung brauche ich
jetzt noch mal kurz wasser auf dann
könnte es nämlich über einen heißen
wasserdampf ganz schnell wieder reich
bekommen was mir langsam auffällt ist
wichtig die musik in der kirche
spezialist mal täglich macht das sieht
man gleich wie es weiß wird und jetzt
direkt führen diese genial
zwar gebe ich jetzt erst mal von war von
dieser hackfleisch füllung in die mitte
jetzt von beiden seiten verschließen
zwar eigentlich weniger youtube-kanal
gemacht denn das hätten wir vielleicht
so ein container war er zweiter wäre es
gewesen dann von diesen leckeren bohnen
das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an
street food deutschland englisch
leistungskurs und salat ich glaube wenn
dennoch länger es dauert jetzt halt ich
hier beide seiten ein
ich habe ein bisschen volk
gajic foul ich kenne solche zufolge
macht ist egal ich schaue mir tut es
trotzdem so es und zwar zum anrichten
also jetzt kann man zum beispiel so aus
der hand direkt essen aber damit sieht
hübsch aussieht und jetzt das innenleben
auch sie lassen es so richtig senkt so
den lauf geschnitten glaube ich jetzt
rein - innere sehen wollt ich zeige es
euch gleich also sieht so aus jetzt auch
gott du kannst du net sei in der gegend
rum was okay ich bereit
wirklich und kommt die scheibe gut durch
aber richtig nicht nur schaffen
ich finde sie richtig gut vor allem kann
man sie jetzt noch so bissle warm essen
also bei mir ist die hackfleisch füllung
noch leicht warm oder man ist einfach
richtig gut durchgeführt warum wirklich
wahr findest du alles klar
dann werde ich jetzt noch die restlichen
befüllen und falls ihr dieses rezept
nach machen wollte ich doch echt ein
tolles rezept also falls das nicht so
schaaf haben wohl bisher weniger chili
oder etwas oder einfach kein pfeffer
weglassen und falls ihr dieses rezept
nach machen wollte das blog täter stets
noch mal ganz genau und ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß machen und guten appetit
und ergebnis
hmm